So, do you think your product
helps them in some way with their business, or
perhaps with their goals?  Y me miran,
me miran con esa cara.  It's like, "Is that what
products are supposed to do?
I thought we were supposed to grow 7% every
week."  These are Dalton and Michael, and
today we'll be talking about setting goals
as a company without
product-market fit.  So, Dalton, we just
launched and I know that if we don't
grow 7% weekly, we're failing
.  TRUE?    I
mean, let me, let me start with
something strong.  Uh, let me approach this
from a different perspective.
Digamos que trabajabas en Google, Meta
o donde sea y sabes mucho sobre
producto y análisis.
Yes.
And you're used to working in
those environments, you come into YC,
yes.
You launch the product, you come and want to
show me graphs and talk to me about your
A/B tests and all that.  And I
ask you: "How many users do you have?"
.  Y ellos dicen: "Tres".
Yes.
And I reply: "Okay."  "No vuelvas a
mostrarme estas gráficas".  Las
gráficas son una pérdida de tiempo.
Measure weekly growth when
you have zero users.  It's like: "We have
three users and they've all left."  "
Entonces, lo que dices es que tienes
cero usuarios".
Yes. Let's
not talk about weekly growth.
Sí.
Y a donde quiero llegar, y sé que
estamos de acuerdo, es que las
tácticas y habilidades de una empresa
con ajuste producto-mercado no tienen
relación...
No....
con medir el progreso y los objetivos
en una empresa en etapa temprana.  De
hecho, noté que los estudiantes
universitarios que no sabían nada de
análisis a veces llevaban ventaja,
porque no tenían que desaprender toda
esa basura de cómo los entrenaron en
Meta para ver si un producto funciona o
no, ¿cierto?
Do an A/B test on the top 1% of Utah and, I do
n't know...
Exactly.  En Meta tienen todas esas cosas
geniales, ya sabes, es genial.  Y si
trabajas en Meta, pues qué bien por ti
que tengas esas herramientas.
Yes. They're useless
when you don't have any
users.
No. But I think you...I think you
dodged the trick question.  Forward
.  I think the trick question is that
growing 7% weekly is great or
terrible depending on how you do it.
I think the brilliance of that advice
is that when you're small, growing by
7% every week isn't really difficult when
you're adding so many users, is it?
Sí.
Creo que la otra genialidad de ese
consejo es que es mucho más difícil
crecer un 7%semanal si pierdes a todos
tus usuarios cada semana.
Clear.  You and I know, and that's where we're headed
, that what people do is
choose metrics that cheat.
Yes.
And they say, oh, we're not going to use
daily active users (DAU), we'll use the
cumulative total of users who have
ever registered.  And we won't
worry about whether they're using the
... Basically, the founders, I think
the term is Goodhart's Law.
What they do is simply find
a way to manipulate the metric in order to
achieve it.  And all you're doing
is ruining yourself.
Bueno, porque la idea es que creo que
crecer un 7%semanal es el resultado de
hacer muchas cosas bien.
Yes.
While they think it's the
reason the company works.  And
when you confuse those things, you
really mess things up.  La cantidad de
veces que hablo con un fundador y le
pregunto: ¿cuántos usuarios tienes?¿
Cuántos de ellos pasaron más de 5
minutos en tu producto?  Actually no,
the first question is a trap.  Es
como: para obtener valor de tu producto
en una semana, digamos, ¿cuánto
tiempo deberían pasar tus usuarios en
él?  And they always say: oh, you know,
like an hour a day.  It's a
fundamental workflow.  Es realmente
importante para ellos.  Y entonces les
digo: genial.  So, how much
time are they actually spending on the
product?  Y siempre hay dos respuestas
que me encantan.  Uno: no lo estamos
midiendo.
They say: Oh, we'll have to
contact you again.
Sí. Es como: solo tienes seis años,
¿cómo es que no lo sabes?  And the
second one: oh, it's like an hour a
week.  And you say: So, you said that
to get value from the product, they have to
use it for a certain amount of time.  Are they
getting value?  Don't know.  And then, you
know, I like to insist.  Es como:
entonces, ¿crees que tu producto les
está ayudando de alguna manera en su
negocio, en sus objetivos?  Y ahí es
cuando...me ponen esa mirada.  They say: Are
our products supposed to
help with that?  Pensé que debíamos
crecer un 7%a la semana.  Yes, can we
get back to the point?
What we're getting at is that if you follow
this line of thinking, you know
where we end up, which is with zero
users.  Basically, you go through this
line of questioning, and you
got us.  And you say, "Okay, I'm
glad we had this little
chat."  Y entonces, a donde nos lleva
esto es, sí, sigue siendo cierto.  The point is, do
n't worry
about the graph when you have zero
users, you're not helping anyone, and you just
want to do something that a few
people will find amazing.
Sí.
Y no necesitas una gráfica para saber
eso.  Es como si
Estás hablando con ellos.  ¿
Tienes a tres personas que aman tu
producto?  Yes. Do you have five
people who love your product?  Y eso, y
siempre pienso que deberías empezar
por ahí.
Sí.
Ni siquiera te preocupes por gráficas,
tablas y el crecimiento semanal.
Solo consigue algo que alguien ame.
TRUE?  En mi experiencia, es casi
imposible tener algo que cien personas
amen y que de alguna manera no esté
creciendo.
Sí.
O estás mintiendo sobre el amor que
sienten o no estás mirando el
crecimiento.  It's very, very difficult.  Y
diría que la triste verdad del 7%es
que, a veces, toma tiempo lograr que
alguien lo ame.  A veces toma tiempo
descubrir qué rayos construir para que
alguien lo ame.
You know, we talk about him a lot, but
our colleague Paul Buchheit created
Gmail.  Y así fue como creó Gmail, por
si no han escuchado la historia, amigos
.  He built it for himself, and
he was the first user.
Sí.
Y luego se lo dio a otras personas
internamente en Google.  I was only adding
one or two people per week.  Les
preguntaba qué necesitaba añadir a
Gmail.
Sí.
Y así pasó por este estado durante
meses y meses, con menos de 100
usuarios, pero él quería construir
algo que la gente amara.
Lo que me encanta de esa historia es
que para cuando Gmail empezó a tener
éxito, ¿verdad?  Ni siquiera era una
distribución abierta, tenía cientos
de personas que lo amaban.    They
love him, and again, love is the word
.  No decían: "Oh, supongo que puedo
tomarlo o dejarlo".  Ellos, ellos
dirigían su vida a través de eso.  And
so, when you think about it, this is the
most popular consumer product in the
world.  I use it every day, you
use it every day.  How did
that product come to life?
Yes.
It was someone who wasn't trying to get
a hockey stick graphic within 2
seconds of creating it.  He was someone who
took the time and care to make
something that a small group of
people loved and were
willing to use in their daily lives.  Y
de nuevo, no puedo enfatizar esto lo
suficiente.  Así es como se construyen
grandes productos.  Pero Dalton, tengo
que recaudar fondos en unos meses y
sabes que a los inversores les encantan
las gráficas.  Va a tomar demasiado
tiempo.  It's going to take too long to
build something that people like.
No estás resolviendo mi problema
inmediato, que es: ¿cómo construyo
algo por lo que los inversores den
dinero?
Yes.
I think that's the classic
self-destructive mindset where what you're saying,
founder, is that you're building
something for investors and not for users
.
Build something that investors will love
.  Yes, that's our motto.
You just presented the argument that
your real customer is an investor.  Sí. Y
nada bueno saldrá de eso.  Again, it's
like saying: these aren't the droids you're
looking for.  Si empiezas a pensar de esa
manera, que toda tu startup es un
producto hecho para convencer a
inversores, no ganarás.
You will not win.  Bueno, está bien, no, no,
no, no, no, no.  Ganarás a corto plazo.
Yeah?  Apuesto a que si eres
inteligente y algo capaz, probablemente
podrías ganar en tu ronda semilla.
But what do I love about that
seed round? What's the percentage chance of
ultimately winning when you raise your
seed round?    It's
not... I mean, it's better than zero
, but you know, it's only... a
2% chance?
Yes.
Okay, so you've just brought your
odds down to a 98% probability
of failure.  ¿Qué tal si en su lugar
dedicaras esa misma cantidad de tiempo
a interactuar realmente con tus
clientes, verdad?  Aprender qué
necesitaban, aprender si alguna de tus
hipótesis es correcta, aprender cómo
mejorar sus negocios, mejorar sus vidas
.
Y cuántas historias tenemos de
fundadores que hicieron un mal trabajo
recaudando fondos en el demo day, pero
tenían medio millón de dólares de YC
y simplemente siguieron adelante y, un
año después, siguieron este consejo
que estamos dando y les está yendo
fenomenal, mucho mejor que a sus
compañeros de lote que en realidad no
estaban haciendo algo que la gente
quiere, estaban haciendo algo para
inversores.  Hacer algo que los
inversores quieren.  Y competir por el
precio más alto.  Yes, nothing
good comes of that, folks.  Regarding your point that
this creates habits in a
negative way.  Como que no quieres que tu
cultura sea
No.
Oh, solo nos preocuparemos por los
inversores ahora, pero después de
recaudar dinero, ya nos preocuparemos
por
bla, bla, bla, hablaremos con ustedes.
Yeah, whatever, guys.
Um, déjame darte otro ejemplo.  Stripe
es una empresa de la que hablamos mucho
en YC.  A phenomenal company.  Es una
empresa de cien mil millones de
dólares, ya sabes, por decir algo.  Lo
que mucha gente no entiende es que no
se lanzaron durante unos dos años.  No
estaban en el lote creciendo un 7%
semana tras semana, o sea, no, así no
construyeron Stripe, hombre.  Era solo
por invitación.  It was only in
beta version.  Lo construyeron para ellos mismos
como un producto secundario.  And they only
added customers very slowly.  Y,
de nuevo, pasaron más de 2 años antes
de que se lanzaran públicamente, ¿
verdad?
Sí. Y recuerdo que en ese entonces,
porque nos lo ofrecieron en Justin.tv
para usarlo, y no era lo
suficientemente bueno.  Yes. We don't
use it.  Y resulta que para hacer un
producto de pagos, como teníamos una
audiencia global, para hacer un
producto de cobro que pudiera aceptar
pagos en todo el mundo,
No simplemente creas un MVP para eso.
Yes I know.  Y hicieron todas estas
cosas increíbles, como cuando hablamos
de la instalación Collison, donde
venían y se sentaban contigo frente a
tu computadora y te ayudaban a
implementar Stripe en el flujo de pagos
.  They were that obsessed with the
customer.  In fact, I was one of
Stripe's first customers at my
startup.  Probablemente fuimos de los
primeros doscientos clientes.  And
I remember Patrick sending me
messages on Google Talk all the time
.  Así que tenía a mi nuevo amigo
Patrick Collison.
Sí.
Como era un cliente inicial,
probablemente hablaba con él casi
todos los días.
Sí.
Y él decía: "¿Cómo va todo?"  Como
si fuéramos un cliente importante para
ellos.  Y qué genial fue para mí, como
consecuencia de ser uno de los primeros
clientes, sentir que mi proveedor de
pagos se preocupaba tanto por mí.  And
a relationship with the CEO.
Sí.
Y que realmente le importaba si
estábamos felices.
Y si algo salía mal
Yo solo podía, pum.  Podía, ya sabes,
enviarle un mensaje.
Yes.
No, I think that's a superpower
the founders never want to talk about.  Y
esto es lo que diré.  Este será mi
punto final.  Antes de la IA, era
difícil investigar cómo ganaban las
empresas.  TRUE?  It was like you had to
review articles.  You need to
listen to a lot of podcasts.  Por
ejemplo, si quieres escuchar las
primeras historias de Stripe, podría
tomarte un par de horas, y quizás sea
difícil.  Y ciertamente, si quieres
escuchar las primeras historias de 50
empresas, eso es mucha investigación.    It
's not easy to accept
popular knowledge just like that.  Ultimately,
with AI, research is easy now.
Puedes enterarte de las empresas que te
gustan.  Puedes aprender cómo eran
cuando eran pequeñas.  And I challenge you to
take any assumptions you
have about early-stage startups
and test them with your 10 favorite
companies.
How long did it take them to launch after
creating the company? How long did it
take them to get 100 users?
How long did it take them to reach one
million in revenue?
Yes.
And you'll be surprised.
Surprised?
De que las historias reales no son lo
que tú crees.
And that doesn't mean you have to
do it the same way, but it's just, hey, get
those things into your head.  Because you see that
graph showing the companies
that reach 100
million in revenue the fastest.  It's like that's
the race...That's not the race
, guys.
Es el valor a largo plazo, ¿verdad?  It's
like...
That's the fundamental thing we try to
do here, create lasting value to
help customers and build
enduring businesses, not something fleeting,
right?  Or at least that's why I
'm here.  Um...
Bueno, no solo eso, incluso si eres...
digamos que eres neutral.
Yes, it doesn't matter to you either way
.
De cualquier forma, ¿verdad?  This is
the way that has the highest
probability of success.  Así que sí,
puedes quererlo porque te gusta ayudar
a la gente o puedes querer ayudar a la
gente porque eso te hará más rico.
Either way.
Sí.
Llegas a la misma respuesta.
What you, the viewer of
this video, should do is be very honest with
yourself.  Do I have any users who love
my product?  And I would use that word.  ¿
Cuántos aman mi producto?  Si no es
así, ¿qué puedo hacer para que amen
mi producto?  Desglósalo y piénsalo de
esa manera en lugar de solo mirar
gráficos todo el día.  Because that
dehumanizes your users.  De nuevo,
si eres Meta, lo entiendo, ellos pueden
mirar gráficos todo el día.  But if you
dehumanize your user base and
only look at graphs, and don't think about
the people you serve and whether they
like you or not, you are hurting
yourself.
Así que tengo una pregunta
controversial que hacerte al final.
We started this by talking about how to set
goals as a company in the
pre-product-market stage.  Have we
answered that question?    Do
you have more than zero users?
So, again, this is what I mean
by YC.  Do you have a real user without
asterisks, you know, how?
Yes.
Okay, then I'd say something like, well, do
you have 10?  And then I'd say, "Are you
50?"  And then I'd say, do you have 100?
Sí.
Y si pudieras conseguir 100 usuarios o
clientes que te quieran, esa es una
meta increíble, y ahí es cuando
empezaría a pasar a las gráficas.  So
, that's more or less the point where I
say, okay, now let's talk about
graphs.
Sí. Y creo que lo único que
añadiría es que me encanta hablar con
startups sobre cómo definimos el amor,
especialmente al principio, para no
engañarnos.  Y lo segundo en lo que me
gusta pensar es si hay alguna forma de
medir el beneficio que le estás
brindando al cliente.  Sure, you worked
with Whatnot.  In a marketplace, it's
really easy, right?  GMV is
the profit.
Our salespeople were making
a lot of money.  It changed their lives.
Así que sí, con Whatnot, alguien
empezaba a vender en la plataforma y
podías ver cuánto dinero ganaban.  And it
was like, "Wow, these people are
making a fortune with this."  It was
obvious that they were adding value.
Digo, DoorDash, un ejemplo similar, te
despiertas y DoorDash representa un
tercio de los ingresos de tu
restaurante.  Okay, you can have your
opinions, but for us at Twitch
, streamers could quit their
jobs.  Eso es lo que desearía haber
dicho más en años pasados, que si
parte del amor, puedes cuantificar el
beneficio real para el cliente en lugar
de solo el tiempo que pasan contigo o
cosas así.  If we could put a
monetary value on the
customer benefit, then we would be on the
right track.  Very good.  Good chat.
Good luck with your goals.  That seems
fine to me.  Thank you, Michael.